if you wait for something to be perfect
you will never do it
you need to be uh
you need to know that marketing is
something that is dynamic you publish
you try you learn all the time the goal
is to be
as close to perfection as you can
without expecting perfection
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is all about marketing meet
emmanuel cohen head of marketing of
walnut io manu leads the marketing in
walnut io he worked for seven years at
wix where he managed the social presence
and blogs and took part in five super
bowl campaigns he has also spoken about
social media content at many marketing
events including social media week most
recently manu created an employer
branding video for walnut that went
viral in israel and he did it in less
than a week
meet manu
manu welcome to 20 minute leaders from
the walnut headquarters how are you
today
i'm great thank you for having me like
i'm i'm used to watching your face on
repeat as i'm watching the walnut
marketing video that went completely
berserky viral recently and and that
really is the topic of conversation here
manu with with a bachelor's from the
hebrew university and a masters in tel
aviv university you've held you know
some of the thing the dream positions
for anybody in marketing whether it's
head of social media at wix and after
growing into that position through being
at wakes for for quite some time i
believe about seven years and then ahead
of content in social media adhere
technologies and now obviously the most
exciting thing in the world being head
of marketing for walnut one of the
fastest growing startups in israel
probably every person in the streets of
tel aviv knows what walnut is and and
i'm very honored to be a small part of
the journey so manu thank you very much
for being here
thank you for having me
uh
really like
being that walnut has been a crazy
adventure
things happen so quickly and so fast and
just amazing to see to be part of it
and particularly in marketing which is
my passion
since i started working in high tech
well so so you know i there's a lot of
styles to marketing and a lot of times
i'm looking at companies and they have
you know a big google spreadsheet with a
bunch of kpis and this post is going to
go on this day etc and all of a sudden i
go and i see
walnut's recent video that obviously
you're you're you're starring in and
and i'm thinking to myself how does a
company and how does a marketing team
come up with something like this as a
part of their sort of kpis can tell me a
little bit about you know this video and
how that plays into your greater
thinking through marketing
so
first of all there is many many factors
that made the video successful first of
all was the timing we had to make it
quickly because we jumped on many tv
trends like a retina there at here like
the
the satire and
and the tv show i was part of and it
just finished so we had to make it very
quickly so
i to be honest it was i wrote it in
one hour so we took to the guys in the
office they laughed i said okay if they
laugh it mean it's good
i
might have made a photocall to uh to a
director he told me okay let's do it two
days after we were shooting it no way
after it was in the air
and uh i think that's the that's the
beauty of the thing it was not over
prepared it was very intuitive we came
up with and that
by the way like when i do marketing i
think that uh people
and particular consumers are very tired
of
classic marketing and the goal is always
to surprise them and to come with
something that
either like to come with them with the
knowledge that they are smart and they
know the rules and to come and break the
rules like all this employer branding
campaign now in the last year in israel
in the i-tech it was madness but
everything is built on a model and what
i try to do there is to break the rules
to come like
a bit like a bit uh
you know from the other side like
selling the
the company without really stealing it
and i think like it's a bit funny that
i'm annoying people and i'm not taking
myself too seriously
uh
not like would what a lot of company
does when there are superstars that come
and
and show off it was like i think more
humble more more funny i don't know
something worked out very well so manu
this sounds this sounds great you know
this idea let's break the rules let's
surprise the audience but how do you act
as head of marketing in this
organization
how do you then strategically create a
culture or create a sort of process in
the company that enables
this type of work
i think that
i'm lucky that the ceo of the company
you have is a marketer so we understand
marketing and he knows to recognize very
easily
uh what kind of what's good marketing
where where you can be original where
you can build a brand
and uh in my and i think we're building
a very strong brand
and and part of it is to understand that
we need
b2b today and that's also our
it's alternating to our products
[Music]
is more
we need to understand that even b2b
consumer even if you have a vp sales
somewhere or a cro in a big company you
are still a human being
and you are still uh basically you have
a b2b approach which is very similar to
b2c meaning talking to people yeah
you know straightforward be a bit funny
about what we do not pretentious if you
look out of social media everything is a
bit cynical we understand you understand
what we are doing so let's make it fun
you know what i mean
and so our website is very alive
like everything we do
is there is a very strong i believe at
the end of the day you create an
emotional connection with the audience
through the messaging through the way
you package it through the visual
identity through the storytelling that
you are
creating
and
if you speak to people as people not
trying to sell them something very very
strongly or to use the old marketing
tricks that everyone knows and see and
already like
can't already see them because you see
you saw them so much
so if you come with a different angle
with a more approachable uh style and
a bit of humor and a bit of
self-derision and a bit of
uh
charm i i would say i think that uh
that's the way i try to
to to market the company and so far it's
going well
uh
so that's really like the the the secret
is to create an emotional connection be
close to people make them feel like they
they're close to you and i will tell you
something like behind the scenes right
when the sales team go on a call with
clients
clients are like oh you're one nut i
love what you are doing you know like
they already feel connected to the brand
in some way that it allows the safe team
to celebrate easily because
it's the rna right correct
[Music]
you know how do you define them kpis
when you're trying to break the rules
because a part of the idea behind kpis
is that you do something systematically
and then you're watching your kpis
perhaps grow or converge over time
you how do you even set a kpi for for a
video like the one that you created
so there are many things there are many
ways to to to measure this specific
video was in player branding so it was
in hebrew it's very specific to the
israeli market so there you will measure
in amount of followers
uh amount of uh cv connections that that
added me on linkedin i think like on the
same day at like 5 000 connect new
connections on linkedin and same for
your ad and for the most people who
share the video and so you can really
see like you know i'm always
laughing with you out that area every
time we do a move like that we seen the
analytics the shark
you know the shark
would you carry the thing
and that's really like how you see that
something was a success like recently
with our rambi
the shark showed up again and like you
know you can see the the number of
followers jumping the visit to the
website jumping particularly uh direct
and organic traffic which is like people
see something and then they look at for
you and
google
pr coverage
uh
of course engagement with your views
like you have a lot of metrics that you
can take together to measure the success
of one specific item take me back to
that same moment where you're writing
that script and you're writing the ideas
you're going to you have and they're
laughing and you realize okay this is my
kpi for this meeting
and you know that that creative process
of of trying to understand how can i
break down some walls that are or some
some some preconceived notions in the
industry how do you work through that
process is it just you know a morning
that you wake up and you just feel like
you know today i'm creative i'm gonna
try something or is it a any methodology
that you have
so that i think that there is both like
first of all you need to know the rules
okay you can't
break the rules if you don't know them
so when you do something like that the
first thing i do when i create a
campaign i go and see what the other
companies did in terms of employer
branding campaign
and i see the patterns i'm like okay
here there is something funny to do here
there is something funny to do here
there is something funny to do
and then i just sit on the
on the computer and start writing
but trying to find the right pattern
understand where are the flows if you
want in the uh
more conventional uh employer branding
campaigns and and then i just i just
jump on them and tweak them around it's
like uh it's all like you know i'm
turning and turning around everything
upside down all the time like
people were expected to see a you know
high-tech and you know and this
prestigious stuff and i enter with a dog
and the first thing people see is like
someone pushing me and i'm like what the
and because i i understand uh social for
a long time and i know what people
react to
instinctively
so you know
the goal at the end of the day is to
keep the watcher watching
through the full thing so you have like
the building blocks which are
what i learned from working on the
companion that i decided since the
beginning to turn upside down and then
there is
the emotional tree girls oh you keep the
flows going quickly so
i start with a dog and then someone
pushes me and then i make it uh an intel
textual joke with uh a latina that's
what i'm saying like yeah the ryan chalo
like this is an idea of his that is good
which is a joke on me yeah and then like
i keep moving so with the title joke and
every like if you want every 10 seconds
you have something else so even if you
are not a fan of the show
and you just so uh the tv ad you will
understand some of the jokes if you are
just working in high tech and just
loving uh to see on player renegade you
will understand the pattern breaking so
from ever
no matter what uh angle you are looking
at it
there is something for you
right now you know you me you're
mentioning that how long did it take
from the moment that you thought of the
idea to the moment that it that it aired
on social media
it took
10 days maybe 10 days but the reason it
took 10 days is because the tv show told
me you can publish it only after the tv
show
finished to earth
but actually it was ready
after a week since the moment i wrote it
it was i think tuesday we shoot it on
friday and next tuesday they send us the
online version so it's like so how do
you balance the you know the
the i'm guessing that there is always
you know wanting to improve right and
i'm sure that even after it was
completed you're like ah this maybe we
can edit this second a little bit better
or maybe we can shoot this
but you're still choosing to deploy it
what what how are you balancing the
perfectionism versus the timeliness here
so that's a very uh very interesting
question uh i think most of the one of
the biggest marketers problem
is not to take risks
if you wait for something to be perfect
you will never do it
you need to be uh
you need to know that marketing is a is
something that is dynamic you publish
you try you learn all the time the goal
is to be
as
close to perfection as you can without
expecting perfection so we had like free
version of the ad
three different shooting we went back
and forth with the with the director and
we tell you okay this i don't want i
prefer this beginning this ending and we
add this back and forth and then we get
to a point that we say okay this is good
enough
i won't lie to you when i press the
publish button
i was scared uh because
it's an ad that i wrote
that i started i'm not an actor of any
kind and uh that i'm putting like
everything like you know i put all my
japans in one item
so it's very very scary and but if you
don't take risks
you don't do anything and that's like
you know that's something that we i
learned from weeks a while ago
they had this on the walls these posters
like avoiding mistakes cost more than
making them
so you need to be ready to do mistakes
you need to be ready like for people to
be to criticize you but otherwise you
don't learn
right
you have to learn all the time that's
the beauty of marketing how did you
decide or how did you realize that your
your passion is in in marketing and in
tech
where did that come from
so uh to be honest like marketing was
always uh uh
i always was fascinated in marketing
since i'm a kid you know the the tv ads
there was no internet back then right
the tv ads was something that i was
always like i always find them
ridiculous but in the same time i was
fighting fascinating but stupid things
were crazy and very uh
very very smart
smart ad like so since i'm uh i'm a kid
i always like i love advertising
and uh
and when i started working the tweaks
and working on social media and you see
uh the
oh oh like a simple post can go crazy
and someone that you enter in the past
that you worked on for half or four days
a campaign that like all the company
worked on is the flop and i tried i
studied like
i presented in the social media week
back then
uh who i analyzed the the reaction why
people react oh they react all the
identification game is very very
important you know people tagging each
other and then you understand the way
like
it's
in my opinion it's fascinating to
understand
what people react to and why
and
that's all marketing like you know it's
about emotion it's about to make people
react without them having them thinking
you know they
they first react and then they read what
you have to
what you have to say right so
i think that
that's the the
in my opinion like as a marketer this is
like fascinating to to
to pass messaging
messages to
to create emotional connections that
in today's world manu
obviously every company has a social
media marketer now uh whether it's in
tech or not tech what are some tangible
things that they can do in your opinion
to understand social better because
right now it seems that
while there are organizations like
walnut that are
that are leveraging their presence on
social media to affect change throughout
the entire company there are other
companies that are either just
stabilizing their brand through social
media you know doing very very normal
down-to-earth content some are not even
really active there what are some tips
for social media marketers that that
you're now telling yourself
so first of all i think that the the
most important tip is that social media
is a playground
it's not a threat right when you are
publishing something on social media the
day after you have another item and if
you failed
nothing happened right so you need to be
you need to be willing
to uh to take risks try stuff and
understand how people react to each and
every item
because if you are trying all the time
as we spoke like really like a few
minutes ago uh if you are trying all the
time to create perfect stuff you will
publish one past a week and it won't
probably succeed because you worked on
it too much social media is
is really like the
[Music]
the the
it's the most interesting lab
to learn about your users
right you try stuff you collect insights
you collect comments you say okay that's
what people love in this post next post
i will use it more and that's the way
you move it's very dynamic
it's not like i don't believe in having
one strategy like you know like i'm
saying okay that's what we're going to
do all the time no you try stuff you
learn you move on
now
i think that from the from what you're
talking about the sphere of failure
right they said this willingness to try
and fail
and and that really nothing happens
do others in the organization see it the
same way because obviously from in the
tangi in the practical way yes people
don't unfollow a page because they've
done a pose that isn't going viral but
could it be that the failure also stems
from the fact that they'll be measured
by the people in the organization
because they don't realize that that
it's okay to try and fail
so i do tell you like as i said
in the company and outside the company
is the same game basically because
at the end of the day
you need to be
smart enough to show that what you know
what you do even if you fail so today
when you get to a point that your
followers uh love you enough
and people in the company trust you
enough based on your formal results
right
right so then only you can uh really
like
the more trust you build the the the
wider you can get right
so uh so that's why i'm saying and i'm
it's very very important
you don't just
try stuff you know the rule you learn
the game and then you can start playing
with the border with what's borderline
and playing with a bit like the
creativity
and how far you want to go like in the
in being
disruptive so that's the
that's really the the the thing you
can't just
go wild in the beginning you need to
know what you do in order to break the
rules
manu i i just want to say that i'm a
i i get inspired by bits and pieces in
this industry uh usually they're the
things that are that are different and
and from the moment that i saw that
video and i saw the reactions that i
don't know part of me said like wow like
this is just there's i'm sure there's
such a cool story behind this idea and
and i'm just you know inspired by the
idea that you know really it comes down
to a marketing team that truly
understands the people that are
listening truly understands the
ecosystem willing to take risks willing
to act quickly
you know executives that are supporting
these decisions that are willing to run
forward and i think you can definitely
get that vibe through the video and then
i'm just very thankful that you came to
share this with me in these 20 minutes
so thank you very very much
thank you so much thank you take care
[Music]
you